welcome back to CBS this morning as we
continue our a focus on how police
officers and sheriff's deputies handle
suspects a ProPublica investigation out
today uncovers disturbing details about
the death of a man in custody in
California
ProPublica says it learned through
surveillance video and documents that
Riverside County Jail staff failed to
address Phillip Garcia's urgent medical
and mental health needs it also found
staff used violent force against him
then lied about it in reports Garcia
died less than two days after his arrest
in 2017 Carter Evans is following this
case in Los Angeles Carter good morning
good morning Anthony Phillip Garcia's
family just to settle the lawsuit with
Riverside County now they say Garcia was
beaten in jail and he died from his
injuries
well now ProPublica has obtained 17
hours of video from inside the jail and
a medical center and we've got to warn
you some of it is very graphic in the
last hours of his life
Phillip Garcia can be heard pleading
with deputies Garcia died shortly after
those pleas and his death was ruled a
homicide according to his autopsy the
cause of death was a mental health
crisis combined with rhabdomyolysis a
fatal condition that can be caused by
overexertion the psychological crisis
combined with the restraints led to the
fatal condition ProPublica reporter Ryan
Gabrielson co-authored the story he said
they believe Garcia arrived at the jail
in a state of psychosis the Sheriff's
Department saw him only as someone who
wouldn't follow orders and that had to
be punished
ProPublica spent months investigating
the case and found deputies repeatedly
struck shoved and twisted Garcia's head
and limbs when he was already tied down
and based on its analysis of records and
video it obtained ProPublica concluded
the deputies falsified Jo logs
then made false statements in their
reports after Garcia died Garcia was
arrested in March 2017 after he
allegedly smashed a neighbor's window
and was found acting bizarrely a family
friend told ProPublica Garcia had a
history of seizures mental illness and
inconsistent treatment after his arrest
the 51 year old was placed in isolation
in a Riverside County jail cell where
he's seen on video acting erratically
ProPublica reports that over the course
of around 18 hours Garcia does not
appear to eat sleep or see a mental
health or medical professional when
Garcia then begins to damage his cell
deputies use a barrage of weapons on him
including a stinger grenade
they are then seen on video rushing in
Robbie Thomas is a mental health
specialist who previously worked at the
jail she spoke to ProPublica after
viewing the footage they should be
trained to deescalate a person and not
right away try to take them down but
it's been my observation and once the an
inmate is to that level it's their will
against the inmates will after 21 hours
in the jail Garcia was brought to
Riverside University Health System
Medical Center but they did not have a
bed for him don't Garcia waits 12 hours
in the emergency room waiting for a bed
in full restraints in a gurney
all the while straining against them a
few hours later Garcia is believed to
have died in those restraints a
government survey released in 2017 found
that inmates have higher rates of
serious psychological distress than the
general population 37 percent of state
and federal prisoners had been told in
the past by a professional that they had
a mental health disorder and 26 percent
of jail inmates reported experiences
that met the threshold for serious
psychological distress when you saw this
video is there anything that struck you
and said I know what this is what I saw
was a very confused disoriented
individual who wasn't able to make sense
of his environment dr. Jill and Biswas
is a forensics
Kyah turist she reviewed the footage of
garcia what is the appropriate way to
approach someone in that state a lot of
what we do is use the least restrictive
methods we can because we do know using
restraints can be extremely traumatizing
this is an opportunity and a moment for
us to think about how we can add
rehabilitative services in jails and if
we can have more conversations and more
cross-training I think ultimately it
would really benefit the individuals who
get incarcerated rather than
hospitalized now we reached out to the
Garcia family attorney and the Sheriff's
Department both declined to comment as
for the medical center it set us a
statement which says quote its goal is
to always provide patients with high
quality care that meets each
individual's physical and behavioral
needs now the family settled their
wrongful death lawsuit for a million
dollars but in it Riverside County did
not it been wrongdoing Tony all right
Carter seems like there's an opportunity
there for several different
organizations to reflect on where things
might have gone wrong Carter thank you
very much